what i hope to do in this fraction is be
able to rewrite the fraction eight
tenths as being something over a hundred
so i could put a question mark here or i
could put a star
over here star over a hundred and what i
care about is figuring out what is the
star equal to 8 over 10 is equal to what
over
100 and i encourage you to pause the
video to think about it
now to help us work through this i have
i have set up a little diagram here
actually two diagrams to think about
what eight tenths looks like and then i
have the same whole instead of being
split into tenths i have it split up
into hundredths i have it split up to a
hundred equal sections and we have to
figure out how many of these hundred
equal sections are equivalent to the
eight out of the ten equal sections
right over here
so let's think about that a little bit
so once again we have 10 equal sections
here and we have colored in one let me
mark them off we've colored in one two
three four five six
seven eight of them this this that this
diagram this picture represents eight
tenths ten equal sections i have colored
in eight of them
now how do i do that if i'm talking
about a hundredths
well it's the same hole right over here
now if i want to fill up the same amount
of that hole
so let me get
a little paint brush here
so
it would be
the equivalent of one-tenth would be
filling in ten hundredths so that's ten
hundredths right over there then two
tenths or that second tenth every time i
fill in the tenth that's the same thing
as filling in ten hundredths let me
write that down because that's
interesting
so we see here that one tenth
is equal to ten
over
one hundred every time i fill in a tenth
every time i fill in a tenth
that's one tenth right over there if you
look at this diagram that's equivalent
to ten hundredths it's equivalent to ten
of those hundred equal sections so if i
wanna figure out fill out eight tenths
that's going to be eight times ten
hundredths or eighty hundredths and
let's just see that right over here so
we already did ten hundreds twenty
hundreds
twenty hundredths this is going to be
thirty hundredths
40 hundredths
50
hundredths
60 hundredths
70 hundredths
and 80 hundredths notice i've filled in
the same amount and i could fill it in
just to make it a little bit clearer but
i filled in the same amount of both of
these equal holes but over here how many
of these squares have i filled in i have
filled in 80. now let me get my pen
going i have over here i have filled in
80 out of my hundred squares while over
here i filled in eight out of my 10
equal rectangles
but they're the same amount of area
they're the same fraction of the whole
so 8 over 10 is going to be the same
thing as 80
over 100 you see it's the exact same
thing we've just divided the one on the
right here into 10 times as many
sections and you could even see it
mathematically that look if we divide it
into 10 times as many sections
so if we multiply our denominator by 10
to go from 10 to 100 well that means
that each of these eight sections in
this one are going to represent 10 times
as many in this one so we would say well
8 is going to represent 10 times as many
of the hundredths so 8 times 10 is 80 10
times 10 is a hundred eight tenths is
the same thing as 80 hundredths and in
general if you're trying to rewrite a
fraction but and and not change its
value so you want an equivalent fraction
as long as you multiply the denominator
or as long as you multiply the numerator
and the denominator by the same thing
you will not be changing the value of
the fraction it's also true if you
divide the numerator and the denominator
by the same thing you also will not be
changing the value of the fraction in
this case we have multiplied both the
numerator and the denominator by 10 and
you see why we did it